Rihanna did you ever meet her and talk
with her she did the enemies she did
Rihanna recognizes a star when she sees
one
[Music]
the singer shined brighter than ever
during her Super Bowl halftime show so
did her sign language interpreter 20
year old Justina miles whose energy
captured the attention of millions
around the globe he's better
[Applause]
I know all the songs I was confident
Justina sat down with CBS morning's Gail
King on Friday and revealed Riri saw
what she did and really loved it I did
not get a chance to meet her but she did
DM me she did
can you tell us what she said she said
she was like black queen yes you're
amazing we BFFs in my head you were oh
you were amazing I would glad we killed
it so she did yeah but it was beautiful
you want to get it right you know
everybody's watching yeah the world
watched and cheered for Justina who made
history as the first deaf female
performer to sign the Super Bowl the
Philadelphia native who's studying to
become a nurse went full out during the
halftime show Expressions Dance Moves
all on ten
[Music]
I got the set list about like five days
before the uh show and I was like
nervous before like getting this I was
like oh my gosh what's she gonna do like
she hasn't been on stage
I'm listening to all your different
songs so do you memorize the lyrics yes
that way I can sign the lyrics and move
to the beat so they can see the beat
rather than they can hear the other beat
yeah to really bring that empowerment to
millions and millions of black deaf
people all over the country who've never
really seen that before
and so I they'll they should feel
inspired and that's the same way I feel
when
I feel like that is truly lifting every
voice even my voice
for Justina
[Music]
and hope these two queens find a way to
make history together
[Music]
[Applause]